hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one of the central concepts that
friedrich nature discusses
in essay number two of his genealogy of
morals
is this relationship between creditor
and
debtor and what it has to do with
the origins of justice as well as a
number of
other things as well and i do want to
point out something
at the very beginning in carrying out
this genealogy
nietzsche is not and so i want to
emphasize this
not saying that the creditor debtor
relationship
as understood in primitive times can be
blown up
as the template for everything else
that's not the way genealogical inquiry
works he's also not saying that it is
the simple origin
of all of these other developments there
are a number of contingent
um you might call them additional
elements that come in and then play a
role and it's not something
that remains itself exactly the same
thing in every circumstance so
we want to be careful not to turn this
into something like a universal dynamic
that explains everything
but it does play a really significant
role in nietzsche's view
and even allows us to uh
get past some mistaken theories
about matters so the the central
question
that he's really engaging with or a set
of questions
in essay 2 are the origins of guilt
and guilt is going to play into what he
calls the bad conscience right
where punishment is deriving from and
there's a whole discussion
of that and then justice where is this
conception of justice coming from and
what is it so one of the keys to this
is this what he calls contract
relations for tags for help me so right
for help
for helpness is a relation between
things
like father and son is a relation you
know in aristotle's
um you know categories he uses that as a
prime example
things that are relational are you could
say defined or characterized or have
their meaning
with the other in their connection with
the other so
without a creditor no debtor without a
debtor no
no creditor and when we see contract
here in the text
we want to be a little bit careful it's
not as if everybody's sitting down
and writing out a contract which would
be governed by the norms of contracts
of today where we say things like well
if somebody doesn't know exactly what's
in the contract it's no longer binding
no no this is we're talking about in the
in the past people are making
agreements arrangements with each other
that may be
another way of translating the fifth
hogs
in this and we do want to talk a little
bit about these terms creditor
and debtor as nietzsche points out
uh schunder right the debtor is the one
who bears a
shuld a debt but also guilt
and and you know these terms are
connected with each other
the term creditor we don't actually
relate quite so well to its origin in
latin
right to believe
and so creditor is one
who extends credit to the other
in um you know german it's actually
gloiber right so it has this sense of
believing
in what the other person has to say and
what are you believing in when you're
engaging in
credit you know we think of it in terms
of money but it could be all sorts of
other
matters as well any sort of tangible
good
that one person gives to another and the
other
promises this is why they're believed
promises to
pay back and may or may not pay back
now why is the promise believed in the
first place
this is a good place for us to to start
right
there's a promise of repayment
or substitution right he says
that uh here we go whence to this
primaval deeply rooted perhaps by now
inner radicable idea draw its power
the idea of an equivalence between what
injury and pain i've divulged it as the
contractual relationship between
creditor and debtor
old as the idea of legal subjects and in
turn points back to the fundamental
forms of buying selling barter trade
and traffic and he goes on and he says
when we contemplate these contractual
relationships
we feel considerable suspicion and
repugnance towards the men of the past
who created or permitted them and and
this is kind of
an interesting side point we'll look
back
on this and we're like well that's
really unfair why would anyone enter
into that well because
this is in the early stages of human
development
and they don't have any sort of
blueprint to compare it against like our
own
highly developed societies with their
own highly refined notions
of what counts as being a good creditor
being a good debtor
anything like that at the beginning like
he says
the here we go to inspire trust in his
promise to repay
to provide a guarantee of the
seriousness and sanctity of his promise
to impress repayment as a duty an
obligation on his own conscience the
debtor makes
a contract or arrangement with the
creditor and they pledge that if they
should fail to repay
they will substitute something else
what can they substitute it could be
money
right but in a lot of cases this is the
creditors giving money
and then the debtor has to come up with
something else
so what else could it be something he
possesses something he has control over
for example his body people could
actually
sell themselves into slavery we often
forget when we think of the origins of
athenian democracy
that one reason why the democracy took
hold
is because the rich were in effect you
know extending
debts to extending credit and then debts
to the many
and enslaving them due to that this is a
very common experience all across
societies that people fall into debt
through this his wife
right family members his freedom even
his
life or given certain religious
presuppositions
even bliss after death the salvation of
the soul
peace in the grave and nietzsche talks
about egypt here
as an example of this where the debtor's
corpse found no peace from the creditor
even in the grave
then he adds another thing above all the
creditor could inflict every kind of
indignity and torture upon the body of
the
debtor cutting off of the proverbial
pound of flesh right
and so he talks about there being a
strange equivalence here he says let's
be clear
as to the logic of this form of
compensation it is strange enough
an equivalence is provided by the
creditors receiving
in place of a literal compensation for
an injury thus
in place of money land possessions of
any kind perhaps even food
a recompense in the form of a kind of
pleasure what is the
what is the pleasure that they're
allowed the pleasure of
cruelty and he spends several different
you know sub-chapters in this essay
talking about that we're going to skim
over that rather quickly except to point
out the
central feature of this what is this
pleasure pleasure of being allowed to
vent the pow
his power freely on one who is powerless
the vault the voluptuous pleasure of
doing
bad for the pleasure of doing it the
enjoyment of violation
and he says the enjoyment will be the
greater the lower that the creditor
stands in the social order
or we might actually say the lower that
the person is brought into the social
order right
because a debtor could in fact be among
the powerful
and what is more you know delicious to
to the people of that time
than to see enemies or or debtors
brought low and then treated as
commoners he goes on and he says
in punishing the debtor the creditor
participates
in a right of the masters so the
creditor
is allowed to take on the the what let's
call it the
the mask the position of the strong
in this primary evaluation and do
whatever they want to do
to the person who's placed in the weaker
position the common person the person
who's no good who's you know not
measuring up to the debts
that they have taken on
and so like i said there's a lot that
nature says about that we're going to
skip over this
the main thing here is that there's this
measuring
going on and i'm going to skip ahead to
that section once we get past
the cruelty and suffering part so he
says
to return to our investigation this is
in chapter eight the feeling of guilt of
personal obligation
had its origin as we saw in the oldest
and most primitive
personal relationship that between buyer
and seller
creditor and debtor it was here that one
person first encountered
another person that one person first
measured himself
against another now isn't that an
interesting and peculiar
thing for nature to say we might we
might
be tempted to say well wait a second
aren't there personal relations
within the family you know father to
child or you know parent to child or
husband to wife or you know
sister brother to each other extending
it into cousins and then we get
these sort of clan type structures
nietzsche
is he's not denying that those exist
but he's saying that this is really
where the true
action is as far as the development of
human culture this relation between
self and the other mediated
in terms of objects and values in terms
of
goods in terms of debts and he talks
about the human being
developing into the valuating
animal the animal that assigns values
vieta
so we've already seen this in the first
essay with the
primary evaluation the priestly
evaluation the
trans valuation that consists in you
know
good and evil now we're talking about
another
kind of valuation that nietzsche sees
happening here and he tells us that this
is
um something that preoccupies the
earliest thinking of human
beings he says setting prices
determining
values contriving equivalences
exchanging
you you can find these in every grade of
civilization
these preoccupied the earliest thinking
of man to such a great extent
that in a certain sense they constitute
thinking as such
and we might consider that
you know when we're looking at ancient
literature
what is the earliest stuff that we have
we have myths
and then we have commercial transactions
don't we you know if we if we think
about
the tablets from mesopotamia a lot of
them are about business transactions
and some of them are about people
complaining hey you you ripped me off
on this deal you didn't pay back in good
measure after i paid out to you
so nietzsche sees this as
radically ingrained in our
human nature you know you could say it's
part of the development of human culture
as such he tells us
[Music]
here the oldest kind of astuteness
developed here did human pride
the feeling of superiority in relation
to other animals have its beginnings
perhaps our word mana still expresses
something of precisely this feeling of
self-satisfaction
man designated himself as the creature
that measures values evaluates and
measures
right and so he says that buying and
selling
along with their psychological
pertinences all these things connected
with buying and selling like being a
creditor or a debtor
promising right are older even than the
beginnings of any kind of social forms
of organizations and alliances
and he tells us it was rather out of the
most rudimentary form of
personal legal rights that the budding
sense of exchange
contract guilt right obligation
settlement first transferred itself
to what the coarsest and most elementary
social complexes
in their relations with other similar
complexes so now we have not just
you know the strong and the weak in
their dynamic and the priest emerging
out of it
we have this entire domain that is
interpenetrating that
of like you said buying selling
exchanging valuing
making promises all of those things are
being
combined with it and this
interpenetrates those
primitive social complexes
he tells us that the eye was now focused
on this perspective
and with that blunt consistency
characteristic of the thinking of
primitive mankind
one arrived at the great generalization
everything has its price
all things can be paid for that oldest
and naives moral canon of justice the
beginning of all good naturedness all
fairness all good will
that things can be exchanged for other
things
an eye for an eye a tooth for a tooth is
actually
a fairly complex expression of this
right because it could be you know an
eye
for a blow it could be
whatever you want here we're actually
going to get to the discussion of
justice
so we've got a very interesting
phenomenon here
there's one other thing to point out
before we talk about justice as such
so in chapter 9
and chapter 10 he talks about the member
of the community
being a debtor not only to other members
of the community but to the community
itself
a notion that we find spread throughout
humanity and that
why was that well he says that one lives
in a community one enjoys the advantages
of a communality
one dwells protected cared for in peace
and trustfulness
without fear of certain injuries and
hostile acts to which the man
outside the man without peace is exposed
so being exiled being set outside of the
community
means being vulnerable in many ways
being a member of the community means
being protected being assured
and so if you break the mores the
rules the laws of the community that
you're already a debtor to
you're kind of a double debtor right so
he says
what will happen if this pledge is
broken the community
the disappointed creditor will get what
repayment it can
the direct harm caused by the culprit is
a minor matter right so
if you steal i don't know from the
communal till
right that's a bad thing but the
community also has to have recompense
for the mere fact that you have violated
the agreement violated the norm and it
can impose an incredible heavy sanction
at first the law breaker as he says is a
debtor who has not only failed to make
good the advantages and advance
payments bestowed on him but actually
attacked his creditor
therefore he's not only deprived of all
these advantages and benefits
he is also reminded what these benefits
are really worth
how is he reminded by the wrath of the
disappointed creditor
the community punishment is like he says
is simply a copy
of the normal attitude towards a hated
disarmed
prostated enemy who has lost not only
every right and protection but all hope
of
quarter as well and then he talks about
how
later on within you know the development
of this the community can actually
afford to be very
merciful but we'll come to that in a
moment so let's talk about justice
where does this idea of justice come
from we we mentioned this
already back in uh the section
here we go section eight where he said
uh the oldest and most naive
naivest moral canon of justice the
beginning of all
good naturedness right and he says
justice on this elementary
level is the good will among parties of
approximately equal power
to come to terms with one another to
reach an understanding
yet another relation right after the
relation has been violated justice means
establishing a new relation and
understanding by means of a settlement
and there's another part to this to
compel parties of lesser power to reach
a settlement among themselves
what is it that a judge is doing a judge
is reestablishing
justice in some way and oftentimes the
judge
has the power to say not only to give a
decision but to
take things away to impose punishments
so
justice is really not coming about from
the weak it's actually coming about
from the strong who can impose who can
compel
this settlement and it winds up
replacing
the conflict and it winds up you know
changing
the debtor relation
so how do we arrive at this
self-overcoming of justice in mercy this
has to do with
chapter 10 he talks about the community
as the power increases a community
ceases to take the individual's
transgressions so seriously
why because there's no longer such a
danger that this is going to
totally undermine society so
the punishments can become laxer and
laxer
mercy can afford to be shown and like he
says
the justice that began with everything
is dischargeable meaning
every debt can be paid for everything
must be discharged ends by
winking and letting those incapable of
discharging their debt go free
it ends as does every good thing on
earth
by overcoming itself
by transforming itself in the process
and he says
this self-overcoming of justice we call
this
mercy and it goes without saying he says
that this mercy remains the privilege of
the most powerful
powerful person or better beyond his law
so it's not everybody who can show mercy
in this respect it's those who are
powerful enough
to engage in and to
apply justice he's also got this very
interesting discussion where he's
rejecting
the ideas of during
about justice coming from reactive
and resentment-filled people that
justice is really just a form
of revenge he says that we have to
reject this
and he says you know
some some kinds of justice can actually
be like that and justice can certainly
be harnessed
by the reactionary but where is it
coming from
in its origin he says that um
here we go the uh
the affects that are really driving
justice are things like
you know lust for power and a little bit
later in that section
he's got a reminder here of his
fundamental point of view
he says to speak of just or unjust in
itself is senseless in itself
no injury assault exploitation
destruction can be unjust because
life operates essentially that is in its
basic functions through
injury assault exploitation destruction
and
cannot be thought of at all without this
character
legal conditions from a biological
standpoint can no
be no other than exceptional conditions
they constitute a partial restriction of
the will to life
which is bent upon power and are
subordinate to its total goals as single
means
a means of creating greater units of
power
so i mean this is nietzsche's basic
metaphysics of the will to power
but justice can play
a role in that when we have
a society in which the strong are going
to jockey against each other
and in which we've got this entire
process
dynamic of extending credit and debtors
not always paying things back we have to
have something that can
restrain that reactivity
the cruelty the you might even say
one-sidedness of it and here we go
um here's here's the
discussion that that nature has of this
um
he tells us that when we look at history
in what sphere has the entire
administration of law hitherto
been at home the need for law in the
sphere of reactive people
no it's the that of the active strong
spontaneous aggressive
from a historical point of view law
represents on earth
the struggle against the reactive
feelings the war conducted against them
on the part of the active and aggressive
powers
who employed some of their strength to
impose measure and bounds on the
excesses of the reactive pathos
and to compel it to come to terms
wherever justice is practiced and
maintained
we see a stronger power seeking a means
of putting an
end to the senseless raging of
resentment under the weaker powers
that stand under it whether these are
groups or individuals
partly by taking the object of
resentment out of the hands of revenge
partly by substituting for revenge the
struggle against enemies
of peace and order partly by devising
and in some cases imposing settlements
partly by elevating certain equivalents
for injuries into norms
and he says the most decisive act
however is that the supreme power
performs
and accomplishes against the
predominance of grudges and rancor
it is the institution of law law starts
to
make things impersonal right a little
bit earlier he talks about this
and he says that um
here we go the last fear to be conquered
by the spirit of justice is the sphere
of reactive feelings when it really
happens that the just man remains just
even towards those who have harmed him
and not merely cold temperate remote
indifferent
being just as always a positive attitude
when the exalted clear objectivity is
penetrating as it is mild
of the eye of justice and judging is not
dimmed even under the assault of
personal injury derision and calumny
then this is a piece of perfection and
supreme mastery
on earth right so what we what we see
here is a transformation
that's taking place early on we have
this
creditor debtor relation that is spread
throughout all society that doesn't
simply displace but actually interfaces
with the
modes evaluation that we were talking
about in essay one
there's this transformation and
eventually
we get a full-blown conception of
justice of rights pervading the
society and and according to nietzsche
nobody really
grasps exactly how this this complex
dynamic
uh you know developing over history
is really happening but it does trace
back
originally to this creditor debtor
relationship that nietzsche thinks is
there in
all societies that have managed any
level of development
you